this is better than any fashion show
besides yeezy that i've ever seen
kanye west makes a rare appearance on
keeping up with the kardashians
ahead of his split from kim kardashian
meanwhile khloe kardashian worries that
her sister is struggling with her
relationship
kim has been struggling with her
relationship
i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
but before we get into that let's talk
kanye's cameo
the rapper made his first appearance in
the final season of keeping up
helping kim with an over-the-top gift
for her mom kris
jenner for chris's 65th birthday in
november
kanye must have moved this thing around
so many times just to make sure that it
looks
really dramatic for when my mom walks in
the kkw beauty founder worked with a
stylist to put together
65 looks for the family matriarch buying
designer pieces and having them custom
tailored to her mom's measurements and
kanye was right by kim's side to help
present the gift in their home
since you're 65 i have
created an experience for you for your
65th birthday i know how hard it's been
for you to find
clothes to wear and trust yourself so i
wanted to help you out
these are for me this is just the gift
that just keeps looking at you again
obviously chris was totally wowed by the
grand gesture when she and her boyfriend
corey gamble
walked into the west house i
cannot believe what i'm walking into
this is one of the biggest surprises
i've ever had in my entire life
i've never thought that anything like
this would happen to me because it's
certainly
so generous so kind yeah and chris said
the whole thing had her speechless
the time and the energy that kim
took is the most amazing gift
i've ever seen in my life it's like my
very own
met ball this wants to go down as one of
the best
days of my life i just ultimately want
her to be happy and look good and feel
confident
and while kanye didn't really say
anything on camera
the moment was filmed just a few months
before kim filed for divorce in february
after six years of marriage a source
previously told et
that kim wouldn't shy away from
addressing her highly publicized marital
issues with the rapper
on the final season of her hit reality
show
and in a sneak peek at an upcoming
episode chloe says she's worried about
her sister who seemed to be having a
tough time with kanye
kim has been struggling with her
relationship
you can always talk to me about whatever
and there's like honestly
nothing to talk about i just roll with
it
of course it will all play out on the
20th and final season of keeping up
and kim previously shared what kanye
thought about her decision to end the
show
what is kanye saying i mean he's like
whatever makes you happy
you know of course the family will be
back on tv in no time since they inked a
major new deal with hulu
and earlier this month a source told et
that kim is feeling like herself again
following their split adding she's in a
quote great headspace and moving on from
this chapter in her life
you